we knew when the Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade that there would
be further actions when it comes to
restricting access to abortions at the
state level and one of the battle lines
now is trying to essentially banish
abortion pills as they are called
medication abortions from pharmacies in
all sorts of states around the country
and there is now controversy involving
involving Walgreens and some other
chains related to this the relatively
new governor of Massachusetts Democrat
Maura Healy has issued a declaration
pharmacies must stock abortion pills the
Associated Press reports the governor of
Massachusetts reminded pharmacies
Wednesday
they are required to stock a key
abortion pill despite a nationwide
effort by anti-abortion activists to ban
the medication the action comes as a
federal judge in Texas is considering a
lawsuit that would overturn decades-old
Federal approval of the drug
Democratic governor Maura Healy issued a
written statement saying they pharmacies
must maintain quote a continuous
sufficient supply of all Family Planning
medications including miffapristone
misoprostol emergency contraception and
contraceptive prescriptions now this is
great but there's already very little
problem with abortion access in the
state of Massachusetts but the most
important takeaway is that this is an
action the trying to block and ban and
prevent these drugs from being available
this is being carried out
by a political movement that claims to
be pro-life
when this is actually an extraordinarily
anti-life thing to be doing limiting
access to abortion pills which is the
next sort of battle that they're
fighting now
it's bad Health policy and it's also
extraordinarily counterproductive to
their own stated goals number one
abortion pills are a safe and effective
way to terminate pregnancies in their
early stages when you limit access to
these drugs it can lead to more unsafe
methods of abortion more dangerous
methods of abortion and it can delay
abortion until later in the pregnancy
which is never an ideal thing to look
for it puts the health of women at risk
it can potentially put the lives of
women at risk unsafe abortions are a
leading cause of maternal mortality
worldwide so when you limit access to
the abortion pills you're essentially
forcing women either to have later
abortions or to have more dangerous
abortions and it's a very bad thing when
you look at the health data now of
course the people that are against the
pills don't care
and to some degree they believe if we
limit access to these pills a lot of
these women simply won't have abortions
altogether
but we can talk about that as well when
you limit access to abortion pills
there's the philosophical issue which is
you're violating the bodily autonomy of
these women women should have the right
to have these tools available and to
decide with freedom and liberty is this
something I want to use or not let me
make a decision about my body and my
health with doctors when you limit
access to these medications you violate
that fundamental principle of Freedom
Liberty and bodily autonomy which these
right-wingers claim to defend but then
let's go to the end okay
think of the economic and social
consequences of this if you succeed if
you succeed at preventing abortions by
making the pills difficult to access
women
if they choose not to have if they're
unable to have the abortion because you
limit access to these pills they might
end up caring to term
and ending up with a child that they
were unprepared for or for whatever
reason did not want to have
you then have a situation where and I
know that this sounds so cold right but
the economic impact you are now going to
have individuals who will lose income
due to time off suffer economic
hardships people who have children that
they don't want to have the outcomes
aren't good for the parent and they're
not not good for the kids and so then
you lose the economic productivity of
that person it sounds crazy to even be
talking about it but this is part of
their entire thing if if that's
something you care about then your
actions in trying to ban these pills are
counterproductive not to mention for
those pregnant mothers who do have the
ability to go to another state for
example to obtain the pills or obtain a
surgical abortion now they are going to
have to take time off
and that's going to have an economic
impact as well so no matter what you
care about whether you care about
philosophy and ethics Liberty and
freedom whether you care about safety
whether you care about economic product
whatever you care about
trying to prevent access to these
medications makes no sense whatsoever
let's look at a couple of wacky things
that have come across my desk over the
last couple of days I do want to play
this clip that many of you sent me from
attorney Alan dershowitz who still says
that he is a liberal and that he votes
against Trump but he increasingly has
been a defender of trump from the
perspective of I'm just giving you the
legal argument Alan dershowitz says that
if Trump were to be prosecuted it would
violate the Bible now do we care about
that well that's a different question
you talk about how this is bigger than
Trump about if you're able to do this to
political opponents and dissidents sets
bad precedent it allows prosecutors to
go above and beyond and it actually
makes us less free
without a doubt there was a South
American dictator who said for my
friends everything for my enemies the
law you can use the law to get anybody
as Justice Jackson said or as the KGB
had said show me the man and I'll find
you uh the crime this is the worst
example in my 60 years of practicing
criminal law of targeting somebody for
prosecution and then rummaging through
the books giving people immunity and
trying to concoct a crime that doesn't
exist and if this is allowed to succeed
none of our liberties is safe you know
today it's a republican who's a Target
tomorrow it's a Democrat let me just say
a little bit about this they keep saying
this nobody is safe if Trump is indicted
what what you mean is nobody's above the
law
Trump's not being indicted if he is
indicted in an absence of any evidence
that he committed wrongdoing we have a
situation where there is evidence and
the fact that he was the president
doesn't put him Above the Law that's a
good thing not a bad thing and the day
after tomorrow it's your uncle Charlie
or your nephew or your niece right
there'd be no limits on what prosecutors
can do to their political enemies and
they're going to do it to people who are
running against them for D.A next and uh
it's just and by the way I think it's
important to say we already see
economically biased prosecution where we
know that there are certain crimes for
which poor people are much more likely
to be prosecuted than rich people we
already have that and the Trump thing
doesn't solve nor exacerbate that
problem
the Trump issue is a different one which
is our president's Above the Law such a
violation not only a violation of
American law and civil liberties it's
actually a violation of the Bible the
Bible instructs Judges two things don't
take bribes that's obvious but the
number one thing is don't recognize
faces and uh that's exactly right yes do
not favor anyone in a court yes that's
exactly right yes continue sorry
no that's and that's why it violates
every core of American value yeah well
fortunately or unfortunately I guess if
you like this argument the Bible is not
controlling the law in this instance
thankfully although if it were up to
Republicans the Bible would actually be
the law of the land and that's a
horrifying reality hypothetically if
there were a court that would hear a
so-called Bible violation then the
Republican party also wouldn't be able
to exist since they regularly violate
the principles of the Bible despite
claiming allegiance to it but that's a
different issue Alan dershowitz once a
widely respected lawyer increasingly a
laughing stock and it really is sad I
don't say sarcastically it said it
really is sad Carey lake has not been
mentioned on this show for a while but
this is just too outrageous not to
mention Kerry Lake now has a new story
about what happened in November the new
story is God told her that she would
lose her election in Practical terms but
she would still quote have the victory
whatever that means Carrie Lake did a
church prayer rally it was completely
ridiculous and cartoonish but here's
what she had to say think I if you
follow me you probably know that about a
week or two before the election I had I
was praying and I just have ended the
Holy Spirit as you're stealing it and
yeah don't you remember how she told us
that right before the election that she
was in her room and the Holy Spirit was
inside of her totally reasonable story
right God gave me a word that this might
not go the way you think it's gonna go
oh really the way I thought it was gonna
go because of what I was seeing on the
campaign trail with the people of
Arizona from all walks of life rather
the rural whether they're a Rancher
whether they're a stay-at-home mom a
businessman a student a youngster we had
come together in this great movement
because we want to have our state and go
in a great prosperous wonderful
direction right and so I figured with
this movement unlike we've ever seen
that was led by God
who used
will lead it and get everyone together
we were going to have a landslide
victory
which by the way I'll let you in a
secret we did yeah
did you really know
[Music]
um
the victory will still be yours but it's
not going to go the way to think it's
going to go so you're going to lose in
the Earthly sense but you will have one
in some other Cosmic sense and and I
just said to him it's all for you
whatever you want whatever you need and
I do believe with every fiber of my
being that we needed to open more eyes
and wait more people up right so listen
take your pick is this a grift or is
this mental illness who's crazier the
person who says this or the person who
believes it and I continue to be shocked
by the amount of time that God has for
American politics Arizona Politics as
well as athletic events and everything
it just it is unbelievable the
detail-oriented nature of this God and
so I as of course everything she says is
incoherent I guess now she's saying we
did win in a landslide just not by the
by the votes but you have the victory
and God told you this a couple weeks
before
at some point
there really needs to be a public
conversation in the United States
about the toxic relationship with
religion that exists among the American
right wing it's not that the right or
the only ones that are religious but
this particularly toxic relationship
where their alleged religious whatever
are uh used in this particular way it's
one of the most toxic things that I've
said before I'm not saying Italy is
perfect in any way but you know in Italy
Italy is a Catholic country and I have
lots of friends from Italy and they all
nominally identify as Catholic
they are all horrified by this form of
religion and its interplay with civil
government in the United States because
being Catholic in a place like Italy for
most people
means something dramatically different
than when someone in the United States
on the American right says I'm a
Christian we're talking about very
different things and this is so toxic
but again
who's crazier Carrie Lake for saying
this stuff or the room full of people
that accepts it you tell me make sure
you're subscribed to our YouTube channel
which you can find at youtube.com slash
the David Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
there is nothing better than being able
to say that all of you fine folks really
are the bosses you are all in charge of
the show in the sense that our primary
source of funding is just everyday folks
like you who listen to the show watch
the show and get a membership at
joinpakman.com I implore you consider
supporting the work we do if you value
it if you think that this is trash then
I don't want your support but if you do
value what we do I would love for you to
sign up at joinpakman.com let's go to
the phones by which I mean Discord and
hear from some of those very important
people the people in the audience you
can find our Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord always use proper show calling
etiquette you get right to your question
you have good audio and all of these
different things it's going to be a
beautiful beautiful day of calls I am
sure I can just feel it let's go today
starting
with Lucas from Massachusetts Lucas from
Massachusetts welcome you're our first
caller let's hope for the best
hey David hi so now why can you hear me
I can't you are you in a in Us in an
echoey where are you in some kind of
Turkish bath or something all of my door
of my dormitory oh you're in the hall no
one else here beautiful what's going on
so this is a loaded question but not
long ago I watched a Thom Hartmann
segment in which he asked the question
if Trump's handling of covet should be
labeled to genocide I understand what
your thoughts are on that
yeah I got a similar question recently
about something related to trans and
genocide I you know I don't find it
super compelling to weigh in on that
because the the truth is you can make
these linguistic arguments one way or
another
um the the reality is that Trump handled
covid terribly and more people died than
would have if he had handled it better
but I don't know that any country
handled it perfectly and I think in
every country some people died that that
could have lived had it been handled
better we had limited information Etc
Trump was particularly bad so which is
the the genocide that anyone died that
didn't have to or that more than in
other countries or it's tough It's
really tough yeah I guess because Trump
there's evidence that he wanted more
blue people in blue states to die
um at beginning
sorry you're saying it is what Trump did
in genocide because
he wanted more people from Blue State to
die isn't he on recording saying that I
might be remembering wrong but I'm not
aware that it was that he wanted people
from Blue states to die but he
ignorantly saw that the early infections
were in blue States because that's where
a lot of the big airports are and he
wrongly thought it wouldn't come to Red
States how wrong he was though
it was very wrong yeah anyway that's the
only question I had
um thank you and uh you haven't seen
this on the show all right Lucas from
Massachusetts thank you so much for the
call appreciate it let's go to Casey
from Kansas Casey from Kansas you're
next today what's on your mind can you
hear me yes I can
okay and I'll and I think social murder
would be a better word for what Trump
did there social murder rather than
genocide interesting okay
but uh
back to my question I guess please
recently
the Joe Biden and Eric Adams
you know how they've pivoted on crime
kind of like the 90s tough on crime era
coming back again I know Eric Adams did
did Trump as well I'm not aware I'm
sorry did Biden as well I'm not aware of
that what did Biden do
well you know how he blocked the recent
DC Bill and he's been you know kind of
like going to the right a bit on crime
pretty much trying to
set himself apart I guess from
progressives and other Democrats who
haven't focused on it as much okay yeah
I'll I'll
concede that at least for the purposes
of your question
okay
but uh
from my perspective at least from the
midterms it seems to me that the
Democrats like fetterman who didn't
Focus as much on crime that they didn't
lose their elections
but the Democrats in New York who
kind of fear-mongered over it I feel
like they kind of campaigned against
themselves in a way by kind of giving in
to like the Republican narrative on
crime themselves that's interesting I
think there's anything to that I think
there I'd need to look a little more at
the numbers and the specific races
you're talking about but I do think that
there's a risk to the focusing on crime
aspect to a campaign which is if the
people you're talking to
don't actually believe that there is a
crime problem wherever it is that they
are it can absolutely backfire and one
of the things that we have determined
is that if you zoom out the violent
crime rate in the United States has been
declining for a very long time yes there
were some spikes in some places over the
last three years at different times but
The Narrative of the dangerous blue
States and blue cities is certainly not
true at the state level you see higher
rates of crime in red States even within
cities for all the talk about New York
City the crime rate and violent crime
rate in Oklahoma city is higher and so I
think the risk which you're astutely
pointing out is if it doesn't resonate
with people if people are sort of like
yeah you know I feel very safe and
they're not talking about anything else
I'm not going to vote for them that is a
real backfire that can happen
it's another thing for me too because
even if people don't feel safe where
they are because they're you know
listening to 24 7 media that's worried
about crime
who are voters going to go for are they
going to go for the Democrat that is
doing tough on crime light right are
they going to go for the Republican
that's tough on crime you know Ultra or
something right so you're saying either
way it's better for whoever is going
hardcore on the crime stuff
well I I don't think it's good for
Democrats at all it's not good for
Democrats either way perspective I think
that you're on to something I think that
you're on to something I think we can
probably try to verify this empirically
I don't have the data in front of me but
yeah I think that you're absolutely on
to something Casey
okay do you think it's a good strategy
for Biden in 2024 to focus on crime or I
don't think no I will so listen Biden's
not focused on crime I agree he's
talking more about it than maybe we
expected or we might expect or you know
might think he would I don't think he's
talking about it so much that it's
really going to be uh detrimental in the
way that you're talking about
okay
well that's all I got thank you all
right thank you so much very much
appreciate the call there's Casey from
Kansas let's go to Ryan from DC Ryan
from DC welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hey David uh great to talk to you again
I've spoke with you a couple of times so
appreciate is my audio okay welcome yeah
your audio is fine
all right perfect
um I wanted to just ask you a policy
related question but around AI I mean I
know there's been a lot of news coming
out in the last two to three months with
Chet GPT and some of the uh language
learning models that are now coming out
for companies to use in kind of a
proprietary way get their own in-house
data and I I was looking at some
interviews I know the open AI CEO just
recently had a big interview with with
CNBC and um my question is really around
the economy and job replacement okay
um you know I it seems that uh chat gpt4
just recently released and you know the
Improvement of AI is not linear it is
exponential and it seems like our the
guard rails from a policy perspective
are just not only are they not there but
knowing that the pace in which our
government typically operates is not at
all exponential and so I have a concern
a around
the economy taking a significant hit and
just this being such disruptive
technology I'm wondering how do we kind
of galvanize
legislators especially legislators that
are not technically inclined to really
kind of listen to some of the the
thought leaders in the technology space
that we need to get these guardrails in
place do you think that that is a topic
that could be relevant in the upcoming
election cycle it seems that I mean I
work in the technology space so I might
be a little bit a little bit more
focused on some of the upcoming changes
but I guess from what I've seen you know
just from what I've seen I mean this is
incredibly disruptive technology and
could easily you know replace large
swaths of the white collar Workforce for
sure so here's the deal first of all on
the potential to replace large swaths of
the workforce I there are two views on
this I'll tell you what they are and
then I'll kind of give you my take one
view is I think closer to what you're
suggesting which is that this technology
is so disruptive that it is going to be
unlike anything in the past in its job
destroying potential it is going to
eliminate entire areas of work and
replace it with technology and lead to
technological unemployment potentially
irreversibly that's one view on the
other side there's the view that says
you know every time in history that
something like this has come along when
there started to be cars and people said
what's going to happen with all the
horse buggy drivers they'll have nothing
to do well the car industry brought with
it the need for mechanics and more
chauffeurs and all these different new
industries were created delivery
services
Etc the technology eliminated some jobs
but it created more okay so those are
the two extremes now the difference may
be
and there are some technologists who say
this is the case that where we are now
these are now destructive Technologies
from the point of view of employment
that's something like chat GPT it's not
going to create more jobs than it
destroys that's what some people say
it's not obvious to me I don't I don't
have an answer to this yet because it is
absolutely the case that there are tons
of things including in customer service
and research and and things that if chat
GPT and those Technologies get better
they still spit out wrong information
regularly right now but if they get
better it's true there are lots of jobs
that would be destroyed but
for people who know how to use these
tools to draw new connections between
things and and and generate new ideas
there are still there's still the
possibility that they will actually
create new jobs in Industries we haven't
even thought of yet so I I just don't
think I'm in a position yet to say
whether it will be the destructive force
some fear it will be or whether it will
be a great thing or it will be more like
Neil Postman says which is there will be
good and there will be bad and it will
come down to how it's regulated
yeah I I completely agree and those are
definitely the two schools of thought I
think a lot of the concern at least in
the technology space is especially the
the difference in the the distinguishing
factor between the kind of AI Revolution
and things like the Industrial
Revolution that created net new jobs is
that the pace of improvement with AI is
exponential in such a exponential way
that is unlike any other technological
Revolution we've experienced in all of
human history yeah that's the argument
that some are making like I outlined
yeah yeah so anyway I just was thinking
about that I'm wondering if you know
from a policy perspective you know if we
do start to see some employment getting
replaced if that will be a relevant
topic for politicians in the upcoming
Cycles I think it should be I think it
should be but I don't know that it will
be
got it hey David thanks again for taking
my call Great to speak with you all
right there is Ryan from DC very very
very important topic and eventually it's
going to be a huge issue
why don't we go next to Tony from the
Bay Area Tony from the Bay Area welcome
to the David Pacman show
Tony from the Bay Area you have to
accept my invitation in order to talk to
me there's Tony
okay hello hello
okay my question is about if
um Trump had the
the uh ability uh and he knew he was
going to be arrested but he had the
ability to flee like Edward Snowden to
Russia for the rest of his life to avoid
being arrested
or facing criminal charges do you think
he would take that option nope can I
tell you why
yes so Trump is a malignant narcissist
malignant narcissists believe that they
are the smartest people in the room they
believe they can talk their way into or
out of any situation there are already
articles from The New York Times And The
Guardian based on sources close to Trump
that Trump wants to be handcuffed he
wants to be walked he's seeing all of
this as a publicity tool he has no
understanding of the actual criminal
legal risk to him and believes that he
will absolutely come out on top now that
may be true but even if it was likely
that it would work out poorly for him
where it might actually make sense to
try to flee to Russia narcissists like
Trump never believe that and so Trump
would not come to believe his best move
is to flee to Russia
uh I agree with you
um and I had one more quick question if
that's okay sure
um
you uh you know what I I just forgot it
so I'll let you go thank you David all
right dude Tony from the Bay Area
beautiful question let's go next to
matayo from DC Matteo from DC welcome to
the program so great to have you on
yeah yeah it's great to be here David
can you hear me yes I can
Perfect all right so I have a pretty
quick question uh it's not political at
all uh so
as far as the memberships go I primarily
listen to your podcast on the Apple
podcast app uh and usually that's with
ads and everything and so I was
wondering if you would ever considered
charging for an ad-free version for
people who just listen to podcasts
through a particular app uh be it like
you know Amazon or apple uh just so that
we we already have it it's a member it's
an existing member benefit when you sign
up for membership there's a link in the
member section where you can generate a
custom commercial free audio podcast
link for yourself and then you just dump
it into whatever podcast player you use
it works beautifully with apple music or
iTunes or whatever it's called these
days so we're we're 10 years ahead of
you my friend
oh yeah no I know about that but uh you
know some other podcasters have like
specific membership ones that come
straight through that app uh and so
there's maybe not people like me who are
willing to double dip who already pay
for a membership but would also just
love that like sort of oh you're saying
like an iTunes only or Spotify only
premium version
exactly because I think that there are
probably a lot of people who just
primarily listen to it from that app
just purely out of convenience it's an
interesting idea I think the concern is
always spreading ourselves too thin and
then I will get flooded with emails from
people saying what's the difference
between the premium podcast through
Spotify versus the one on your website
that I can add to Spotify so let me look
into that but I I would be concerned
about spreading ourselves too thin and
just creating a customer service
nightmare
okay makes sense just wanted to ask that
question because there are you know
crazy people like me who are willing to
double dip yeah uh and get both uh but
yeah thanks for taking my call all right
thanks Matteo from DC and by the way one
more thing YouTube is launching
podcasting in and of itself through the
YouTube music thing and everything we do
is going to be available there and I
think the functionality will will be
fantastic let's take a very quick break
we're going to go right back to Discord
and hear from more people so if you're
holding on to talk to me don't go
anywhere we're going right back in a
moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from some more people via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord let's go to
James from Texas if you're with us James
I would love to hear what's on your mind
today
long time fan can you hear me yes I can
absolutely all right long time fan thank
you when I first discovered you it was a
interview with Peter Joseph oh welcome
remember Peter yes I do the Zeitgeist
Movement guy yes excellent so my
question to you is Peter Joseph Jacques
Fresco uh these two individuals
published multiple films and Peter wrote
a book and in which they've discussed
the decline of society based on our
current economic model
that produces the negative results we're
seeing now as in more mass shootings
more mental illness
Etc do you believe that this is the case
that the economic system we're in right
now is
incapable of lasting and is going to
continue producing these negative
so incapable of incapable of lasting is
different than will continue to produce
negative externalities so here this is a
huge topic James and a really great one
um I uh so let's see where to even start
of course
the economic system within which we live
influences our daily lives in many ways
and in the same way that you can say
well the economic system allows us
access to things we like cheap stuff
diversity of food all these different
things right things things that we think
are good
Innovation all these things it also
creates negative issues we haven't yet
fully dealt with the negative
externality of pollution that industry
produces there's too much inequality we
have crime we have mental illness a
Health Care System that's not working
all of these things right on both sides
of the Ledger are partially a result of
the economic system a lot of times sort
of like typical
grad school Master's level analyzes kind
of end there and they often end up at
like well I don't know capitalism is the
problem and like I guess maybe for some
people socialism would be the solution
or for people like me it'd be social
democracy or whatever the case may be I
do think that understated in some of
those analyzes are the impacts of what
we know from sociology and psychology
and hard sciences and all these other
things now those who say no no no no no
no
the economic system influences all of
that our psychology and Society is
influenced by the economic system yes it
is but it's not only influenced by that
so my view is I think people like Peter
Joseph and the late Jacques Fresco
have very interesting things to say
about the way that many systems affect
the way any one of us lives day to day
what I don't like is once or I don't
agree with is when some people become
too focused solely on the economic
analysis and I don't think we should
minimize the economic analysis but we
should make it much more robust than
just that
excellent and um one more question are
you planning to do interviews again and
would you consider having Peter back on
after Zeitgeist 4 comes out we we do
like 15 interviews a month or something
like that 10 interviews a month yeah so
it's not we're it's not considering we
do interviews all the time and I would
be glad to have Peter back on the show
sure
excellent I'm looking forward to it all
right James from Texas thank you very
much for the call I appreciate that why
don't we go next to
oh I don't know maybe uh George from
Virginia George welcome to the program
what is on your mind today
hey David uh can you hear me yes I can
awesome
um I'm still traumatized from my last uh
microphone malfunction yeah I'm hoping
that today we can sort of like clear the
air on it
okay uh so I was wondering if you've
seen like
how there's been an influx of like
people attacking the idea of remote work
yes I have seen that
um so there was recently article
published in the New York Times
by Stephen Ratner
and it's called is working from home
really working and like
this guy tries to blame sbv uh collapse
and metas failures on remote workers
and I can't help but feel like
I'm being attacked because I'm a remote
worker and like
I don't know what their motives are but
it's very disappointing so I saw the
article
um I read a lot in the last couple of
months Pro and against remote work
I actually think that we don't have
nearly enough information yet to say for
sure what are the long-term impacts of
more set in stone remote work we are
very early in you know we had the
pandemic and a ton of stuff went fully
remote and then right now we're still in
a sort of experimental phase where you
know a lot of my friends who are lawyers
at corporate firms they have to be in
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday but Monday
Friday they work from home or other
people it's we have a rotating shift so
like part of the workforce is Monday
Tuesday Wednesday part is Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday parties Wednesday
Thursday you get the idea I don't think
we actually have enough information yet
to say a hundred percent what are all of
the impacts of work from home there have
been studies about so-called
productivity
and what's often repeated is
productivity is no lower when people are
working from home because even if
they're distracted during the day
because home and work are at the same
place they end up kind of just like
doing work at more times or whatever the
case may be for me it's like it's less
about that my view is just a little bit
different my view on this is
it can be better or worse for different
people and companies depending on what
the priorities are right even when you
talk about productivity I don't know how
many people in my audience listen to Cal
newport's podcast it is phenomenal one
of the few podcasts that I actually make
a point to listen to he has a number of
recent episodes about this sort of thing
and in one of them he talks about you
know when we talk about being productive
for some people productivity means
squeezing a ton of different things into
a limited amount of time and so you got
to get organized for that for others
productivity means actually I want more
free time so for me being productive
means squeezing the things I'm expected
to do into fewer hours to then free me
up to do other things or whatever the
case may be a lot of this George is
based on perspective what do we mean
it's good or bad to work from home is it
good or bad productivity wise mental
health socially environmentally and I
just think a lot of people are
expressing opinions about this right now
and the jury is still sort of out on it
yeah I I agree with that David and I
want to say you know I am a coder so I'm
I am an introvert so it does benefit me
to work from home and I realize there's
other people where it does benefit it it
like it actually helps them to work in
an office
but I just want to say like you know
you're right we don't know and people
need to stop being so confident about
you know blaming someone for failures at
the top yeah there was this clip of
Malcolm Gladwell basically saying
working from home is like ruining
everybody's life or whatever it's like I
don't know about that I'm not that that
seems like a bit much and I know he's
being controversial
um and trying to be titillating but yeah
I just I think we need a lot more
information and we not everybody will
agree on what it means to successfully
work from home and unless you first say
what are we measuring it's gonna be very
hard to get definitive answers
yeah you're exactly right uh so yeah
that's it for my call and I really
appreciate it all right George from
Virginia really appreciate hearing from
you let's go with Co with some caution
and trepidation to Oz from Kentucky Oz
last time we heard from you you weren't
doing great and I'm hoping that you're
doing better today
hey can you hear me yes I can
yeah I'm doing a lot better David uh I
haven't talked to you in a couple years
actually I don't think has it been that
long
I don't think I've talked to you even
since my grandma passed away from Coven
in like 2000. oh well I'm sorry to hear
that
like uh I ran for congress did I tell
you that yeah yeah we spoke around the
time of that
oh okay I don't I didn't I I didn't
remember telling you that well I ended
up I ran as an independent against
Thomas Massey and I ended up getting uh
10 000 and uh
I think ten thousand over ten thousand
votes I got four percent of the the is
that right
so I got the most votes for an
independent in my District's history and
I think I'm the only open socialist
that's ever ran in this District so oh
they see it right is it okay to say your
name I mean you're a public person can I
say your name
sure yeah so I'm seeing here the results
Ethan Osborne you got 10 000 votes four
percent of the vote that's fantastic
that's good I mean Massey is sort of
like a big time incumbent
yeah he's uh he's won every election
since 2012 when he took office yeah
which is pretty he's one of the
fascinating
Margaret Taylor green as far as his
politics so what's what's next now
um I don't know I I think I'm just going
to help other people I have a friend
who's running as a Democrat for State
Rep and I'm just I think I'm just going
to help other people's campaigns uh next
cycle
and I'm just more focused on organizing
and um you know direct action and
activism for now
um that's fantastic and listen Oz you're
doing it in a place where it's so needed
which is Kentucky I get calls all the
time from people who are basically ready
to abandon their red States because they
need to for their family or for whatever
reason and I respect that but I also
greatly respect what you're doing which
is you're staying in the place and
you're doing what you can to improve it
yeah it's and it's tough too I mean
we've got some real
problems with fascism here that's
getting worse in this area
um
and I'm I have I don't have much choice
because you know I have shared custody
of my son until I turned until he turns
18 so right
um so I'm here for him
um wow and so well listen I hope that
you will rack up some improvements be
they modest or big in in your area this
is the critical thing how can we improve
the place where we live and that's what
you're trying to do
absolutely yeah I think everyone grouped
in mutual Aid networks right now as much
as possible because uh I think the left
needs to start prepping I think that's
imperative
yeah there is a left prep Movement by
the way that's an interesting thing you
bring up listen Oz it's so great to hear
you sounding so good I really appreciate
you calling in
thanks for taking my call all right
there is Oz from Kentucky four percent I
mean listen it's nothing to sneeze at
nothing to sneeze at whatsoever uh and
so uh so great to hear from Oz all right
everybody we will take calls again just
not today okay just not today I'm out of
time and I will speak to everybody very
soon quick break and then right back as
the Friday show continues
subscribe to our YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the davidpackman show
watch the full hour-long show individual
Clips all of our interviews and
everything else from the show and when
you subscribe make sure to click that
Bell button to be notified about every
new video
all right let's get into the Friday Feed
Bag AKA Friday feedback you can email
info at davidpackman.com sometimes we
will highlight for your uh viewing and
listening pleasure or displeasure a
Facebook message that we receive or a
YouTube comment that we spot or could
really come from anywhere uh yeah let's
just get right into it first message
today came from Cheryl via Facebook
Cheryl says hi your sir are an idiot
when told by our auto reply that I'm
unable to reply to every message
individually
Cheryl added yes tell him to get his
facts right we here in Florida love our
governor and the job he's doing so pull
your head out of your ass and get
someone else besides Ruth left-wing nut
to rebutt her I don't have the slightest
idea what Cheryl is talking about and
interestingly we get a ton of messages
like this and it really is unclear to me
like I know that it's not that these
folks aren't native English speakers I
know that that's not the case sometimes
out of morbid curiosity we will look and
it'll be like oh no Cheryl was born in
you know Jupiter Florida or something
like that
um and is uh is a native English speaker
so are these
typing problems are these voice to text
issues why is it that the emails and
messages I get from right Wingers are so
overwhelmingly disastrous when it comes
to
syntax and format and everything I don't
know I don't know
um Vivian calexilos says I dare David
Pacman to have an intellectual
conversation live stream with Russell
Brand and see how he holds up maybe a
little humbling would do him some good
but only big brave people rise up to a
challenge like this so it won't happen
I want to explain to Vivian and others a
little something okay
um I get emails all the time saying well
if you think Russell Brand is so wrong
about stuff have him on your show if you
think Ben Shapiro is wrong have him on
your show you won't because you're
scared we invite all of these people it
is they who don't want to be on now in
their defense maybe my show is two small
potatoes or small bananas for them fine
but it is not because I'm scared that
they aren't on this show it's because
they don't respond to our requests to be
on Russell Brand is welcome anytime
and Vivian it's not because of me that
he's not here it's because he doesn't
want to do it which is his right I don't
think I have a right to debate Russell
Brand the way some of these right
Wingers say but Russell's welcome
anytime
uh the anti-trans rhetoric is very
strong among the right-wing elements of
our audience right now Christopher uh
put on YouTube quote I mean so talking
about my daughter I guess I mean if you
want your daughter to have to use the
same bathroom as a six foot three
bearded muscular man more power to you
the rest of us will make sure to protect
our daughters wives mothers and other
biological women in our lives
you know when I see something like this
I really wonder
is Christopher really a dad like where
my mind really goes to is to that
because I have to tell you I know so
many people who have daughters myself
included
and the trans bathroom issue quite
literally never enters my mind now I
understand right now my daughter is two
feet tall she can't even walk so the
idea that she's gonna end up in a
bathroom by herself or whatever like I
get that it's not an issue but even when
I think about the next five years the
next 10 years and the things that you
know going to school and travel and camp
and all these different things the trans
bathroom issue doesn't even enter my
mind as an issue so it makes me question
like what's going on in Christopher's
life
that this is really what he's thinking
about or is it all made up does
Christopher not really have uh a
daughter Cuba
um on uh I guess CRT Marxism trans stuff
Cuba says he was right it's taught my
daughter is in Middle School in
California and I've seen her homework
assignments when I was in high school I
had quite a few Marxist teachers this is
America we believe in capitalism and
free market if you don't like it move to
Cuba ask any Cuban American why their
family left and they'll tell you the
horrors of socialism listen I'm the
wrong guy to make this argument too
um I have never been a defender of the
Castro regime I wanted normalization of
relations with Cuba because the Embargo
was hypocritical it was a double
standard and I try to avoid absurd
double standards but I that was for the
benefit of the Cuban people it was not
because I am a defender of the Castro
regime so I am very well aware that
there is this overreaction among many
Cuban Americans Cuban Americans are one
of the few
um groups of uh of Hispanic Americans
that regularly vote for republicans and
part of it is because of their
um aversion to uh Cuba and the Castro
regime they see even like food stamps as
Socialism or Marxism which of course
it's not
um so I I'm the wrong guy to do the go
back to Cuba thing too by the way I've
never been to Cuba anyway but I would be
interested in visiting user one who
sleeps not posted on Reddit and this is
an interesting topic is David putting
too much emphasis on Ron desantis's lack
of charisma Pacman is frequently
referred to desantis's abysmal lack of
Charisma and pointed out that he
certainly doesn't seem to have the same
energy Trump had in 2016. seems true
enough but I wonder if it really matters
art depicting of trump often Slims him
down to a ridiculous degree his stream
of Consciousness bellyaching at rallies
has been hailed as some of the greatest
speeches of all times by his followers
his extensive and obvious political
failures have been recast as
Machiavellian 4D chess moves to trip up
and ensnare his enemies Evangelical
preachers have praised this lecture and
Thief as a true man of God or the tool
by which God will restore the country to
Greatness I don't think desantis's lack
of Charisma will matter one bit people
see what they want to see and I don't
doubt their memes and leaders will help
them see DeSantis in an implausibly good
light
I don't think so
and here's why the reason that
everything Trump does is seen as a great
thing by Trump's followers is that many
of Trump's followers are people who
never followed the political system and
many of them never even voted until
Trump arrived on the political scene
they are a different sort of voter and
the DeSantis voter as I currently
understand the DeSantis voter to be is
someone who is more engaged with
politics and is a little more connected
to reality than the average Trump voter
and wants something different than Trump
so my opinion right now and this could
change is that the average DeSantis
supporter or potential disanta supporter
would be much more influenced by the
reality of DeSantis and would be less
willing to recast every aspect of
DeSantis as a positive trait the way
that Trump supporters are because
fundamentally Trump supporters and
non-maga Republicans are very different
groups I want to hear from you on that
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe my perspective is
wrong Demon King commented on YouTube as
a trans woman I just don't feel safe
anymore living in a less than
Progressive state is taxing it's a shame
that I have to carry defense items just
to feel safe
thank you David for always reporting the
truth as you always do they will not
stop until they have something else to
Griff to history is unkind to anyone who
chooses to try to suppress anyone's
rights well you know I am reminded
of Arnold Schwarzenegger's recent
12-minute video that he did last week
or the week before and he says in it
the people who try to deny others rights
they end up being losers in history and
he talks about his own Nazi sympathizing
father this is Arnold Schwarzenegger
check out the video If you haven't seen
it and so I do maintain hope and quite
frankly I do think it's likely that the
anti-trans people will end up losers I
mean listen the anti-gay people have
basically ended up losers gay marriage
is now legal nationally it's more
acceptable culturally than at any point
in American history of the modern
political era so the anti-gay people are
increasingly losers they're both losers
legislatively and they're just losers
when you you know at this point it is
far more common that if someone just
casually uses the f word to refer to gay
people
most of the people around them are going
to look at them like what that dude what
are you talking about why using that
word so the anti-gay people are
increasingly losers
My Hope Is that Arnold is correct and
that the anti-trans people also will end
up being losers and history will be
unkind to them but the concern is in the
short term they can really make a lot of
people's lives very miserable and that
is what I want to prevent but very uh
good and sad comment there William
commented about my practice of removing
the free Bibles left in hotel rooms from
hotel rooms when I travel Williams said
David I understand you have a right to
remove a Bible from your hotel room but
I'm curious why if it's in a draw I
think he means drawer if it's in a
drawer out of sight how is it offensive
well I never said it was offensive I
understand you are of Jewish faith are
you not allowed by your faith to have
the Bible in your personal space it is
not a question of what Judaism allows me
to do I'm not even a religious person
here's the way I see it
when I
rent a hotel room or you know Reserve
stay in a hotel room
I am looking to stay in a room that
provides me a comfortable bed
maybe free coffee
a TV Wi-Fi a clean and comfortable
bathroom
a quiet room far from the elevator so I
can get a good night's sleep you know
whatever
I am not looking for nor do I consider
it something that is appropriate to
provide me a hotel room that is all
those things plus it provides Christian
reading materials first of all why why
Christian reading materials why not some
other it doesn't make any sense I'm not
looking for a hotel room that is all of
the things I mentioned and gives me
Christian reading material
so what I do I'm not mad at anybody
I'm not looking to have anybody arrested
I'm not looking to have anybody insulted
is I just put that free Bible left by
The Gideons out in the hallway or in the
recycling bin I'm not offended it's not
that I'm not allowed it's just I'm not
looking to stay in rooms that have been
pre-populated with the allegedly sacred
texts of one of a thousand religions
it's just not what I'm looking for so I
just do my quiet thing and I go okay
I'll just take that out the towels I
want the free soaps I'm looking for a
nice conditioner to try to get my hair
under control great but the Bible is
just not part of what I'm looking for in
a hotel room so if I happen to see it I
don't go looking for it if I happen to
see it
I just put it out in the hallway like a
room service tray a couple people wrote
to me and were offended many people
wrote to me and said they do the same
thing one person canceled their paid
subscription I'm not gonna hide from you
that that's something I do if I remember
and I'll be honest many times I stay in
a hotel one night for some work thing I
don't even come across the Bible I don't
even check it was probably there it's no
big deal
it's just not a big deal everybody
remain calm please we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com replace the guy who
canceled his membership because I put
the Bible in the hallway and you can use
the coupon code 24 starts now to get
yourself a discount